I've been covering basically every one
of these coronavirus task force press
conferences live on YouTube twitch
Facebook and most recently
live-streaming on Twitter as well if
you've not been watching them your
mental state is probably much better
than that of people who have been
watching them because they really are
these propaganda explosions but I want
to highlight two moments that are just
complete microcosms absolutely the
epitome of what we're dealing with here
Donald Trump when asked specific
questions about numbers ventilators
masks how long this is all going to go
on when and how many tests are and will
be available Trump retreats to vague
generalities and weird statements and
Trump during one of the weekend press
conferences was asked about thermometer
availability are they available should
they be distributed should people be
buying thermometers and Trump instead
talked about just how stunning it is
that there are infrared thermometers not
a very new technology as you may know
which can take people's temperatures
from a few inches away this is what we
are dealing with the person in charge
right now is surprised and stunned at
infrared thermometers this is from my
stream over the weekend so you'll you'll
hear me laughing which is what I do to
avoid crying because of what's going on
I've seen things when Toni mentions
thermometers they aim something at your
forehead they say this far away bum and
they tell you what your temperature is I
said I've never seen that before
Trump's takeaway from all this is hey
infrared thermometers exist
this guy is operating on a totally
different level than anyone who has any
business dealing with this crisis and I
don't mean at a higher level I mean at a
lower level and during the same press
conference Trump was increasingly
tripped up about ventilators we have
about a hundred and seventy thousand
ventilators in the entire country now
somewhere between five and many more
times that number of ventilators will
likely be needed during this pandemic
the US has ventilators in a strategic
stockpile
insists were getting ventilators we're
getting people ventilators were getting
more ventilators we're sending them
everybody's going to have them never
tells us when never tells us how many
and Donald Trump here retreated to
expressing shock that hey did you know
ventilators are a machine not everybody
knows that take a look at this
horrifying and sad clip you know a
ventilator is a machine it's a very
complex machine and to think that we
have to order hundreds of thousands
nobody's ever heard of a thing like this
you know when we had in the stockpile we
had thousands in a stockpile thousands
ready to go that's a lot all of a sudden
you need hundreds of thousands and
you're not talking about you know the
mask is whether it's plastic or whether
it's material that's one thing but
you're talking about a very
sophisticated computerized machine and
delicate wait a second all this time
ventilators are a machine now adding
insult to injury Donald Trump said it's
a very complicated machine only to have
Mike Pence show up a minute later and
say the opposite Mike Pence actually
said it's such a simple machine not a
complicated one that we're looking at
retrofitting other devices to make
ventilators take a look at this
it doesn't include what will be produced
as the president said we're seeing
companies step forward
well these manufacturers tell us that a
ventilator actually isn't a very
complicated piece of equipment and many
of them are literally surging forward to
create more ventilators os-- so it is a
very complicated and sophisticated piece
of equipment or it's not these are our
leaders right now not by choice no Ebola
czar and of course we are not in good
shape with these people in charge there
are so many levels of ugly going on here
this is just one of them and it's it's
truly depressing